dictator mama qadhafi ruled libya for
more than
40 years but when the end came
it was fast in 2011
the people rose up in mass protests
rebels killed gaddafi
the dictator was gone
but the country has been in chaos ever
since
fragmentation is the best single word to
describe
what's happening in libya a large number
of actors
and communities and groups all
effectively competing against each other
militias extremists and many
international powers
are ripping the country apart and there
are even
two rival administrations each claiming
they should be in control so how did
things
get so bad and so complicated in libya
let us unpack that for you
first let's take a look at the bigger
picture
and what's at stake libya has a long
coastline
right at the doorstep of the european
union
this has made it a major stepping stone
for people looking for refuge
or a better life in the wealthy north
the governance chasm in libya has
enabled
you know the rapid growth of things like
human smuggling through the country
we've seen of course that this can allow
a breeding ground
for extremist groups libya is also
home to africa's biggest oil reserves
and this
puts it on the radar of other countries
any
disruption of the energy supply coming
from libya also
important for for europe but also
because it constitutes the the door to
africa to some extent so the country
if the situation was better who could
also play an important role
as a platform between europe africa
the middle east and possibly further and
most importantly
there are six million libyan people
desperate for a safe
secure future thousands have been killed
in the fighting
hundreds of thousands have been
displaced from their homes
and more than a million need
humanitarian aid
we can trace the roots of this situation
all the way back
to 2011.
the popular protests known as the arab
spring
swept through the region dictators fell
like dominoes
and libya's strongman gaddafi was no
exception
but the way he ruled made libya
ill-equipped
to get back on its feet
what gaddafi operationalized as a system
is a divide and rule system
to dilute the relevance of anyone you
would deem or any faction he would deem
potentially a political military
opponent
either by purging them or kind of
marginalizing them from his patronage
network he used both his tribal
knowledge and his tribal skills but he
is
he also used religion as well to control
the the population
once gaddafi was gone tribes and
militias which had united to get rid of
him
turned against each other
in 2014 a disputed election
plunged libya into the abyss
key civilian institutions like law
enforcement and the judiciary collapsed
but as we heard earlier two rival
administrations emerged
both claiming to be the real legitimate
government there is a legitimacy vacuum
in libya all of the institutions or the
governments that exist today
have had their mandates expire long time
ago
the only reason that these institutions
or these political classes or
political leaders exist today is because
of circumstances
it's because of the failure of the
democratic transition
what makes it even worse the country
sits on the division line
of a fundamental rivalry that runs
through the entire region
competition for power inside libya
between
domestic players uh extended uh
originally and more internationally we
could also see in this confrontation
between the two camps
two different models of power competing
in the post
arab spring era if you can say a
division
between what was called at the time the
islamist camp versus the others that
could be described
as nationalist more military
oriented et cetera two broad but
distinct models of power
one largely based on political islam and
the other
largely based on militarist nationalism
and here's how that's played out in
libya
the side considered to be part of the
militarist nationalist camp
is the house of representatives and
general khalifa
he leads what he calls the libyan
national army or lna
and is based in the eastern city of
tobruk
the lna is supported by russia saudi
arabia
the uae in egypt egypt shares a long
border with libya
and cease haftar in his lna as the best
way to prevent extremist attacks
spilling over that border
[Music]
along with the uee and saudi arabia
egypt also sees haftar
as a bulwark against the spread of
islamic groups like the muslim
brotherhood which
they consider a terror organization
on the one hand you have those regional
and international actors that have come
to the conclusion or to the idea that
there's a need for a strong man that
could contribute
to restore authority and so for them
stability authority and even
military authority are perceived as
the priority on the other side
you have the un-recognized government of
national accord
or gna it's considered to be part of the
political islam camp
is led by prime minister feis saraj and
is based in the capital tripoli
the gna's international backers include
qatar and turkey
turkey wants drilling rights in the
mediterranean
but also has a shared ideological
framework with the gna
namely political islam and support for
the muslim brotherhood across the region
the coalition that has brought together
the gna
turkey qatar represents an attempt to
bring together
those forces that have opposed military
rule
some islamist element and political
islam has also been an important
component but not the only one
you also have european countries like
france and italy
backing opposing sides each saying they
want stability in the region
but regardless of intention all of this
has led to a feeling
that this isn't really about libyans and
their future
sometimes uh people question
whether what we have in libya is
actually a civil war
or an international war that's being
fought on libyan
uh soil and in libyan skies the rivalry
between the two administrations reached
ahead
in 2019 when haftar tried but
failed to conquer tripoli
the country has been at a chaotic
impasse ever since
international focus is often on libya's
fate as a battleground
for regional proxy warfare many libyan
people
feel they don't have a seat at the table
we have now gotten to a point
where what libyans think or what the
aspirations of the libyans people
are have become irrelevant because of
the level of foreign interference
in this country meanwhile daily life in
libya is hard
and is getting worse i have family there
i have friends there
located in all the geographic sides of
the country and under under
both the administrations i wouldn't say
that they want
specifically the same thing uh
institutionally speaking uh or that they
have the same views
over legitimacy but mostly what libyan
people want is roughly what
every kind of citizen in this world
wants good governance
sustainable authorities employment
opportunities
some freedom of expression
they overthrew the regime before if
neither of the two administrations which
claim legitimacy improved their lives
might the libyan people have the courage
to challenge both of them
we have seen some genuine videos of
mothers of
young people coming out on the streets
and airing these grievances
of deteriorating living conditions of
insecurity of young people being taken
to war or leaving the country on boats
to europe
this is an indication that people or
or the citizens might have a certain
threshold if that
is crossed then they will come out in
the streets
[Music]
you